van lee gives it up
gets it right back shot clock at five
he'll pull it three oh
big hit for fred van vleet here's van
bleet
and here's the difference though that is
a very difficult but boston going to
their driving kick game
getting much higher quality shots a
block by van vleet from behind
ciaco gets to the middle grand williams
is on him ciaco
gets his own and puts it back kemba
walker now one of six from behind the
arc
ciacom and look at smart just picked him
austin now with 11 steals in the game
tough defense by toronto here shot clock
at eight walker
pull up jumper is good and a foul
kemba walker a chance at three
gets into his sweet spot there wide open
and then ciaco averaging 15 in this
series
not shooting the ball well turning the
ball over tonight he has just really
really struggled
now he gets blown by on the drive if
they have a kick
in him tatum goes right by siokel for
the finish
turned it over six times they've got
another one of those stretches going
right here
with six turnovers ten point game needs
something to happen and norman powell
gives him something home norman
powell with a big bucket for the raptors
boston up eight lowry probing gives it
up ciaco looks hesitant
now siakim goes to work ciaco with a
finish wow
boy recovered he didn't know what he
wanted to do at the beginning
but scores the basket inside it's a
six-point game
gets a foul tough shot right here on
grant williams
grant williams does a good job
approaching the two-minute mark
toronto down six with the ball lowry a
little hesitation now he goes to the
basket
left-handed layup for kyle lowry tatum
guarded by ciaco gets by obtain of no
and it's into the hands of ziyakum here
comes powell
powell with smart defending oh it's
blocked by smart
what a play on the other end coach oh
that's an
incredible block by marcus smart and a
great job by kimball walker
and jaylen brown getting back down the
floor kimball walker
and jaylen brown getting back down the
floor
chance to make it a two possession game
it's all kimber here
leaves it and oh williams the
[Music]
all right so kyle lowry is out he's two
for two
during the regular season williams shot
72 percent
and he missed the first toronto still
very much
in this boat and tatum is foul
tatum went high for the rebound got
grabbed
tatum now seven of nine from the free
throw line
his two misses have come this quarter
five plus in a game seven the other
is idle kobe bryant
misses still a one possession game one
out of two for tatum
but toronto just somehow they stay in it
here's vanvleet brown is on him toronto
down
three shot clock down to nine
van blee we'll get it set up with ibaka
two-man game here
now williams on the switch he's an
excellent defender van glee puts up a
prayer
and it's it knows they actually ran a
brad stevens play there to try to get
the freestyle damn bleed he doesn't
anna know be great effort but that's it
that's it that's a ball game
the boston celtics hang on to win game
seven
and they will advance to the eastern
conference finals
and for them hopefully brian they get
gordon hayward back
early in that series and that should set
up as an
outstanding